the power of Christ compels you does it
Jay the studio [ __ ] hated the idea of
us playing ourselves I know what
happened you guys dropped acid didn't
you Craig doesn't have any pants on he
got [ __ ] wild probably dance sweat it
all over the place you got white [ __ ]
all over your mouth Frankie you probably
sucked somebody's dick Jonah over here
probably watched and jerked off okay I
didn't even know you're in town good to
see you why are you high when you wrote
this movie definitely parts of it yeah I
think that's apparent when you see the
movie you probably want to go with the
sativa if you're writing all day just to
keep you awake I would say if I don't
[ __ ] Michael Sarah tonight I'm gonna
blow my brains out and the script uh
Michael Sarah slaps Tree on his ass
and and she doesn't hit him back in the
script but he asked her can I slap your
ass for real and she said you could slap
my ass for real if I could slap you back
in the face for a reason on the fourth
time she like smacked the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of him so hard
and she like cupped his ear and actually
like whacked out his equilibrium and he
had to go like lay down in his trailer
for around half an hour